[Musique]
salut à tous nous sommes le jeudi 15
décembre 2007
[Musique]
je souffre et il ya quelques jours mais
37 bougies et je profite de cette
période pour prendre une bonne
résolution
je tiens un blog actuellement monsieur
gros point fr je vous invite d'ailleurs
à les faire un petit tour
j'écris absolument que de choses qui me
passe par la tête ça plaît pas forcément
à tout le monde
j'ai souvent eu des critiques mais en
tout cas ça fait vraiment marrer à
partir d'aujourd'hui j'en ai vraiment de
changer de support
j'adore le blog que j'adore internet
j'adore écrire des choses je vais
continuer je ferai un petit peu moins au
lieu de faire du blog je vais faire du
blog
et ça je vais faire avec les mêmes
régularité à une époque sur monsieur
greu j'écrivais des antiques absolument
tous les jours tout ce qui me passait
par la tête et je vais faire exactement
la même chose sur youtube je vais faire
des vidéos tous les jours du lundi au
dimanche
sans exception ça fait un petit moment
maintenant que je baigne dans l'univers
des médias et d'internet
à une époque j'avais un premier site web
qui parlaient tous qui étaient sorties
et loisirs
ensuite je suis parti plus tôt sur de la
prod au visuel j'ai travaillé pour des
grosses boîtes pour des plus petites
boîtes j'ai fait différents types de
prod
à chaque fois c'était sympa et
franchement je me suis bien marré
[Musique]
quand j'étais plus jeune j'ai aussi
travaillent dans le spectacle le
spectacle je me suis éclaté j'ai vu un
paquet de concert j'étais technicien
sont j'ai travaillé sur de nombreux
concerts j'ai aussi monté des scènes
pousser les caisses beaucoup sué écouté
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de bonnes
musiques écoutées aussi un paquet à une
époque je faisais beaucoup de vidéos
beaucoup de vidéos pour les autres
beaucoup de prod mais jamais pour moi
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
décidé de faire mon blog en vidéo
directement tous les jours pour ma part
je donne rendez vous demain pour la
suite des aventures et merci d'avoir
regardé avant de partir vous montrer un
truc je suis sur un lac qui est gelé ça
tient pas mal quand même
ça se bouge
on va casser
juniors
[Musique]